I was inspired to write the neglected
voter whiteman the Democratic dilemma
because what I noticed in the 2004 race
presidential race was there was this
glib mention of the NASCAR dad so I
actually took a look at the data and
when I was stunned to notice when you
actually look at the exit polls and the
polling going back to nineteen eighty
especially when the gender gap came onto
the national scene in 1980 the emphasis
for almost a quarter century was on
Democrats ability to win women and
Republicans problems with women but if
you actually look at the polling despite
hundreds of stories hundreds of
political science papers all the TV's
pieces on Democrats drinks with women
what actually occurred was that the
Republican Party one man and the
Democrats lost man and that made the
female quotient among Democratic Party
looked stronger so certainly the
Democrats have remained strong with
women have gained strength with women
and particularly the Democrats are added
a really great position today with women
regardless of whether Hillary Clinton
wins the nomination or not but what
happens in in 1980 as a crucial turning
point with trends that began in 68 and
earlier is that absolutely clearly that
the Democrats lost man and the fact that
the base fact behind the Republicans
ability to win five of the last seven
presidential elections that turned out
was that the republicans won more went
men than they were losing women so why
so that was the question what was that
the republicans were doing to win man he
had not turned off women what was this
masculine appeal and so i looked more
into data and what I found was going
back to nineteen fifty two was that if
you divide 1948 excuse me is that if you
divide the income brackets between
working class middle class and wealthy
the Democrats beginning in 48 in most
potently in six to eight and nineteen
eighty lost a quarter of working class
white mad they lost a quarter of the
rows of our coalition while losing
almost no women in the
in class in the middle class they lost
about nineteen percent of women but they
lost twice that amount of man so the
fact is that the Sundering of the
Democratic majority was a story of men
and this was simply missed it was simply
told Paul gender gap was told only as if
women were one where the only gender out
there and it's not to say that the story
of women in politics is an important of
course it was and of course as they
suddenly became a majority of voters
this story became even more important
but that didn't explain how the
Republicans rose and came to dominate
again five the last seven presidential
elections so with all that data in my
head I drove between the two
presidential conventions in nineteen in
2004 I drove the whole country from
coast to coast stopping in all 19 swing
states and just talking to hundreds if
not thousands of voters one conversation
after another and it was in that journey
would that I noticed and encountered so
many men who weren't actually even in
2004 happy with Bush they weren't happy
with the war in Iraq they had misgivings
but they couldn't even conceive of
voting for a liberal and all the all the
weight that that word carried to them
and all that meant and everything that
John Kerry had come to symbolize to them
because I remind you I was driving in
August and it's that month of the swift
boat veterans for truth ads came out so
it was really a poignant moment and
really American put mr. to drive the
country and talk to people it wasn't
that drive that I realized that it's not
just that the gender gap ms was
misunderstood it's not just that the
Republican majority came fundamentally
from winning men from the Democratic
Party but it was also that there was
something deeply American and human and
sociological going on here with you man